yeah okay thank you so many photos so
fast I like a baby a baby a baby every
now and then as a parent you're going to
be that parent that's going to post a
picture of their kid it's going to
happen just accept it and move on I'm
not going to post that with the with the
hat that her mother crocheted I mean
come on she get out of here [ __ ] nut
makes my heart doesn't it oh yeah my
heart my heart is leveled up I've been
practicing portrait photography on my
off time and I found a lighting setup
that makes really good Instagram photos
I think you'll like that's become a
problem in the studio is everything here
is topless everything comes from the
ceiling you start creating shadows under
the eyebrows and dark shadows over the
chin and it can look very threatening
let's fix that simple thing that I do on
the salmon eco channel is I put a light
on the camera Michael LED so that it can
go even brighter no what happens is you
can see that the shadows get a little
filled up more importantly you have an
eye light you can see the 35mm
now that we have an eye light on main
source of light still coming through the
ceiling we need to utilize it so I'm
going to use a basic bounce board go
right underneath the lights angle it
slightly bounces right up into his neck
so now we need to add a beauty light so
the big connector that got on the board
there's green wire in a black wire with
your paperclip into that and the other
the dips clip goes in the pins go into
the black wire and then you flip the car
just beyond positions the fan should
start up and this is going to tell you
if the power supply ourselves is dead or
not the worst case scenario I'm going to
shock myself and it's going to feel like
a 9-volt battery and I flip the power
switch to nothing
come here plugged in the movie put
[Music]
something right everything happen a
little bit part orgy and computers all
of their powers or - no no - Sam don't
come in a half information all right
that's not what happened I tried all
just this the power supply that's dead
or not yep goes on now
can you turned on the whole thing's on
now
the power supply some enough power let's
just try to play back in some please the
next good set this story is evolving in
any different directions one way it now
now we don't know where it's gonna go
it takes wisdom hambone alright because
my phone got indicator all right get
this fellow
[Music]
you're we turn into an hour thank you
let me use we call the true from a
beauty light Amron lights just it
reiterate we have the ring light to give
an eye light filling the shadows of the
hair this is to completely fill the
shadows under the neck a little bit off
of the brow now I'll add my Beauty light
[Music]
once you turn on your beauty light your
face might be really bright don't forget
to adjust your exposure for the
inverse-square law
google that if you don't know what it is
after 120 with the new Fresno light we
have have a nice focus edge light on in
[Music]
look at me now just make sure your
lights are exposed and you're ready to
take the photo
like the most manual video you'll ever
make now you got to get everyone else in
the studio good luck like what's going
slow
my queen emits low and so he opens it up
and heats play and it starts playing
like a slideshow the Edit that is Jake
let's see let's see how fast your
internet is and you click on it and
turns out he's or any other fede fast
100 megabits per second that's a very
slow everyone else and the offer once in
the office is operating at gigabit speed
so he was operating at 10 percent speed
of everyone else after MSI gaming Pro or
are you sure to support its plug into a
folding a bit ports inside these gigabit
for playing to a different uniform let's
see what the - that's running at that
one Giga business so I will just be jank
because sometimes they just are so
smooth every single frame rendering
every detail coming through every pixel
from you if it's up to half listen first
of all this isn't my computer supposed
to be all high-tech and [ __ ] and
apparently it can't even figure out
which megabytes gigabytes bit speed if
we have to run that ok mister I wouldn't
make it by gigabyte disk speed I'm on it
look how many people you've got caught
up in your friggin order of yours like
if premier not going to glitch you maybe
rely on it is this eight-ball reliable
no is this April as reliable as Adobe
Premiere
I'm not going to happen that let me send
it yes definitely look at this
I've now closed premier and reset it
three times because all I just opened it
also I think its own I'm pretty certain
that you remember how my audio drivers
were crashing yeah it's that vent open
it happens in Adobe software maybe they
fix it see this update option fixes it
you know my favorite premier bug is the
random red frame that happens when you
decide to export your media encoder yeah
that one's great all
come on boys even worse now do it didn't
worth
Oh God
[Music]
you want some pretty photos for your
daughter's to remember you by my
favorite part about burst mode is when
you have your subject in motion you're
capturing micro moment
[Music]
you